Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Du hast Themen mitgebracht. Na dann leg mal los.
Naja, wir müssen schon über Jeffrey Epstein sprechen. Du verfolgst das sehr regel oder wie sieht dein Medienkonsum da aus?
Ich habe, es gibt ja immer das Thema und dann das mediale Dings dazu. Und ich frag mich die ganze Zeit, ob sie wirklich so katastrophal dumm sind oder ob es eine Strategie gibt. Und die einzige Strategie, von der ich glaube, dass sie so, aber das wäre auch total erhinnrissig, dass man jetzt einfach alles veröffentlicht, weil man gerade denkt, ja so in 25 Prozent der Amtszeit hofft man, dass es bei 35 Prozent dann absch und bei 75 Prozent und dann sind Wahlen und so weiter und so fort. Also dass man einfach so einen Zeitpunkt wählt, wo man sagt, nee bis November ist noch so und so lang und so weiter.
Und ich glaube, das wird ja auch so kommuniziert, dass man sagt, mehr gibt es auch nicht, mehr gibt es nicht zu veröffentlichen, weitere Infos wird es nicht geben.
Und da sage ich, diese Strategie ist so doof, dass ich sie mitmache. Also sobald mir irgendwas wieder unterkommt, wo ich denke, wow, nochmal ein neuer Ding, nochmal neu irgendwie, mache ich einfach eine Story draus. Weil ich denke, das wird ja nicht aufgehen. Nur weil die das als Idee haben, dass man jetzt so langsam die Temperatur erhöht und dann ist irgendwann so, ah ja gut, okay, wir haben uns dran gewöhnt. Also ich glaube in dem Falle wirklich nicht an den Gewöhnungseffekt.
Nein, das glaube ich auch nicht.
Von daher denke ich mir all in.
Wo Teams vernetzt sind und Ideen wachsen, liefert Internet at Work von Vodafone Highspeed für ihr Business. Together we can.
Ich meine, das, was wir jetzt gerade haben, ich habe die These schon ein paar Mal gemacht, aber das, was wir jetzt gerade als sogenannten rechtsradikalen Backlash in der westlichen Welt haben, wurde ausgelöst durch, ah nein, eventuell gibt es irgendwo eine Regelung, dass man mal was gendern muss. Und jetzt frage ich mich natürlich, was für ein Backlash wird es geben, weil irgendwo echte Menschen irgendwie Babys gefuttert haben, weil sie dachten, wenn sie die unter Stress töten, entsteht da irgendein Hormon und so weiter. Und von daher denke ich mir, ja, schöne Strategie, das langsam Durchsetzen der Gesellschaft mit diesem Thema, in der Hoffnung, dass es abfällt. Du gehst aber jetzt noch weiter als das, was gerade publiziert wurde. Nee, das wurde alles so publiziert. Also, dass es so einen Stresszustand gibt, in dem man im richtigen Moment die Menschen dann töten muss, weil dann die Organe mit diesem Hormon voll sind, scheint Theorie dieser ganzen Bande zu sein. Und jetzt gerade ist es halt so ein Sexskandal, weil wir das so ein bisschen kennen. Und Ice White Shut ist ja auch ein Film, der das thematisiert, wie auch immer. Aber dieser Epstein, da hat er wohl wirklich diese Idee, auf seiner Insel sollen immer gleichzeitig 20 schwangere Frauen rumlaufen, damit da genug Material einfach da ist für diesen Irrsinn, den sie da hatten und so. Von daher weiche ich gerade nicht ab von dem, was publiziert ist.
Wie würdest du aber dann doch die Rolle der US-Demokraten einschätzen? Denn die haben ja lange Zeit das sehr runtergespielt, haben dann aber plötzlich eine Idee gehabt, vielleicht kann Trump über die Epstein-Files stolpern und sind dann sehr für Aufklärung, was dann sogar so weit geht, dass sie dann fordern, dass Bill Clinton und auch seine Gattin Hillary sich bitte äußern sollen, die das dann lange verweigern. Jetzt wollen sie doch vor dem Kongress sprechen. Es ist ja doch ganz erstaunlich, dass die US-Demokraten lange Zeit das unter den Teppich gekehrt haben. Und auch wenn ich jetzt mir die deutsche Medienlandschaft ansehe und es tut mir ein bisschen leid, das zu sagen, aber es war ja doch so, dass eigentlich an diesem Epstein-Fall und an einzelnen Enthüllungen am meisten Springer tatsächlich dran war und eigentlich da immer wieder zu publiziert hat. Auch schon damals, als es den, und ich sage das hier auch ganz bewusst, angeblichen Selbstmord gab, an den ich natürlich nicht glaube, sondern ich würde sagen, da sind noch andere Mächte mit im Spiel. Und dass man da das immer sehr runter gedrückt hat von anderer Seite, also nicht bewusst im Sinne von, wir wollen da nicht zu publizieren, weil wir gesagt bekommen haben, wir sollen das nicht tun, sondern wir haben einen Diskurs gehabt, der sich mit Verschwörungstheorien kritisch auseinandersetzte und zeigte, wie schnell solche Verschwörungstheorien oder manche sagen ja auch Erzählungen entstehen, wie die Struktur dieser Erzählung ist. Und das ist ja auch wichtig, sich die Geschichte der Verschwörungstheorien anzusehen, zu sehen, wie ja damit manipuliert wird, also indem man solche Spin-Doktoren anstellt, die dafür sorgen, dass die eine oder andere Verschwörungstheorie dann so verfängt, dass plötzlich damit ein Wahlkampf bestritten werden kann. Alles gut und schön. Aber man hat im Zuge dessen, also der kritischen Auseinandersetzung mit Verschwörungstheorien, bisweilen so getan, als gäbe es keine Verschwörungen. Ja. Und es gibt aber Verschwörungen, wie wir jetzt hier in aller Deutlichkeit sehen. Und sie betreffen Leute, die sonst als Wohltäter auftreten. Nicht alle. Also wir haben natürlich auch Leute wie Howard Lattnick oder Trump da drin. Von denen haben wir nicht vermutet, dass die Wohltäter sind. Und wir bekommen es da auch nochmal bestätigt. Aber wir sehen eben auch andere Kandidaten, wie beispielsweise Bill Gates, die dort auftauchen. Oder die von der Adelspresse so geliebte Mette Maret, wo man jetzt sagen muss, die ist jetzt nur da erst einmal aufgetaucht mit, sie trifft sich regelmäßig mit Epstein. Ich wundere mich aber auch, wie das alles sein kann, dass man einen verurteilten Mann hat, der 2013, meine ich, aus dem Gefängnis wiederkommt, wegen Mädchenhandels und all dem. Und dann ist er aber so eine Elite.
Also 2008 wurde verurteilt damals.
Okay, dann war es vielleicht 2011. 2011, ja. Und er kommt aus dem Gefängnis, also er ist verurteilt, kommt aus dem Gefängnis. Und eine Woche später trifft er schon wieder Damen aus der High Society, die mit ihm essen gehen. Und er macht so eine kleine Image-Kampagne für die ein oder andere Kronprinzessin, die dies und das werden will. Ich meine, das ist doch, also wie kann das sein? Also wie kann es sein, dass diese Leute, trotzdem das alles bekannt ist, diese Nähe weiterhin gesucht haben? Also es ist ja eben nicht so, auch wenn die das jetzt mitunter so darstellen, als würde das jetzt ihnen klar werden, was das für einer war. Sondern wenn ja schon jemand deshalb im Gefängnis war, dann ist es ja schon sehr eigenartig, wenn ich mich fünf Tage später melde und sage, wollen wir nicht was essen gehen?
Ja, sehr viele Fragen. Ich röre sie mal von hinten auf oder von vorne auf. Also hier in meiner Podcastlandschaft hieß es schon immer keine Angst vor Verschwörungstheorien. Ja. Und als Trump eins regierte und es hieß Fake News, habe ich gesagt, mir ist das halt fabriziert. Dass sie dann auch noch gelogen sind, ist das Problem. Aber man kommt nicht drumherum und zu sagen, Nachrichten sind grundsätzlich mal fabriziert. Manchmal passieren Fehler, manchmal passieren Lügen, wie auch immer. Das Drama ist gar nicht so groß. Und zurück zum Thema, also unter diesen beiden Maßgaben. Also hier schlummert ja, weil du es nach den Demokraten fragtest, mehrere Skandale. Ich habe ja gerade meine Verwunderung darüber geäußert, dass Pam Bondi diese Sachen jetzt einfach veröffentlicht hat. Unter der Idee, dass man das irgendwie so langsam köchelt und dann faded es wieder aus.
Du musst sagen, wer Pam Bondi ist.
Also die von Trump eingesetzte, seine Justizministerin. Und der Todd Blanch, also ihr Vizier, der ja Trump damals schon verteidigte in seinem sechsten Sektor. Sein ehemaliger Anwalt. Genau. Also die haben jetzt diese Idee, wir kochen das langsam und dann wird das schon die Leute, ein paar Storys, aber mehr wird nicht passieren. Die Alternative dazu ist ja, es nicht zu veröffentlichen, aber das Material zu kennen. Also Fotos wie da einfach zwei Hühnchen liegen, um zu essen bereit gemacht zu werden und dazwischen aber ein menschlicher Körper. So und der wird aber dann redacted und dann fragen sie sich, warum? Und dann hat man aber vergessen, den Fuß mitzuredekten. So er ist ja völlig bescheuert. So, diese Entscheidung, das nicht zu veröffentlichen, aber das Material zu kennen, hat auch ein weißes Haus getroffen, nämlich das von Joe Biden. Was bedeutet, beide Administrationen stecken ganz tief drin, sind da ganz tief verbundelt und haben jeweils für sich eine Entscheidung getroffen, von denen ich sage, die sind beide total doof, aber es gibt keine dritte Alternative. Also entweder veröffentlicht oder halt nicht. Jedes weiße Haus hat jetzt eine der beiden Entscheidungen getroffen. Was bedeutet, wir als normale Leute sind jetzt wirklich in einem existenziellen Kampf gegen die Mächtigen. Und auch jemand, der das nicht möchte, ist halt trotzdem da drin. Also man ist ja positioniert durch Vermögenswerte oder politische Handlungsfähigkeit oder was auch immer. Und wir sehen gerade und wir haben uns schon jahrelang über Elon Musk als der dummste und gleichzeitig reichste Mensch der Welt. Und jetzt lassen wir die Politik immer unter Gemeinwohl laufen und stellen fest, ne, gar nicht, genau das Gegenteil. So und jetzt muss jeder für sich und mit muss meine ich jetzt wirklich muss. Man kann es auch einfach auslaufen lassen und dann hat man halt auch eine Entscheidung getroffen. Also die Duldung ist erst mal eine richtige Handlung. So man muss sich jetzt selber ins Benehmen setzen, in welchem Verhältnis man zu Eliten grundsätzlich steht.
Ja, so und das und ich will da nicht hören. Ja, Elitenkritik ist generell problematisch. Die ist erst mal sehr wichtig. Und wir haben ja das Buch hier im Salon besprochen von Rutger Brüchmann, der sagte Ja, diese Mächtigen sind alle irre. Die haben schon etwas gemeinsam.
Irgendwas stimmt da nicht mit denen. Und jetzt sehen wir, das können wir da sehen.
Und es ist ja auch in dem Sinne konsequent, wir thematisieren hier im Podcast fortwährend, dass diese Mächtigen sich über Regeln, zum Beispiel über Regelungen, wie man besteuert hinwegsetzen können, ohne Probleme, also wie sie sogar so weit gehen können, dass sie als Amazon-Chef noch ein Kindergeld beantragen können, weil sie bedürftig sind. Also, dass sie im Prinzip weniger Steuern alle zahlen als wir. Warren Buffett hat ja auch das mal genauso in aller Ehrlichkeit gesagt, mein Sekretär zahlt mehr Steuern als ich. Also, die sich über all das hinwegsetzen können und eine ganz eigene Logik verfolgen, die mit den Privatschütz durch die Gegend fliegen, weil sie sagen, es ist angenehmer und all das. Und dass die natürlich dann auch sich über andere Gesetze hinwegsetzen. Also, was da eigentlich entstanden ist, ist eine Aristokratie in noch viel schlimmeren Ausmaßen, weil die Aristokratie natürlich noch so einen gewissen Kodex hat, der mit einer Moral oder so verbunden ist. Aber das ist wirklich verbunden mit einem radikalen Nihilismus, den man da sehen kann, der wirklich nur darauf aus ist, zu sagen, ich mache das, was ich will, weil ich es geschafft habe, steht mir das zu und dann zugleich möglicherweise zur Kompensation oder weil man auch nicht die ganze Zeit bei Epstein auf der Insel sein kann, macht man irgendwelche Charity-Projekte oder kümmert sich um die Bekämpfung von Malaria.
Also in diesen Dingern sind grundsätzlich ganz traurige Geschichten drin. Also Elon Musk, der am 25. Dezember.
Morgens früh.
Also schon im deutschen Maßstab, okay, die Geschenke gibt es am 24. Dezember. Und man ist am 25. Dezember genervt von, ach Familie, ich möchte raus, wie auch immer. Also man kann sein nahes Umfeld einfach überhaupt nicht ertragen, so. Nur in Amerika gibt es ja die Geschenke am 25. Dezember. So während die Kinder die Geschenke auspacken, schreibt er, ich brauche unbedingt eine Party, kann ich mal schnell hier und so weiter, ja.
Schreibt er dafür F-Bing, ja.
Das ist doch nicht, also wer soll das erklären, so.
Ja.
Und da gibt es so ganz viele, ja. Du hast jetzt gleich diese Melinda- und Melinda-Gates-Geschichte und so. Ich kenne den Clip noch nicht, aber ich habe natürlich auch mitbekommen, wie sie so darüber redet. Und lauter solche Sachen. Also wir haben es hier wirklich mit, also wir müssen es uns noch verdeutlichen, ja. Die Visualisierung fehlt noch, weil wir können jetzt nicht direkt diese Serie Altered Carbon zum Beispiel, wo die Superreichen einfach auch in Kilometerhohen über den Wolken, Türmen leben und da so ihre eigenes Leben und dann haben die schon so menschliche Körper entwickelt und tauschen sich da immer aus und sind im Grunde unsterblich und so, aber so in diesem Maße sind die ja geistig entrückt einfach. Die wissen nicht mehr, was sie mit ihrem Geld machen sollen, also kaufen sie sich so das Blut von Babys, dass sie dann nach irgendwelchen Ideen und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt ist ja diese Frage, was bedeutet das für jeden Einzelnen? Also wir haben den Auftrag, unsere Bundesregierung zu fragen, wie sie dazu steht. Ich finde, mit so einem Regime kann man gar kein Business machen, egal was es kostet. Also dann müssen wir einfach hier wirklich jetzt Microsoft Word ausschalten und mal gucken, wie die Unternehmen zurechtkommen. Was konkret bedeutet, sollte ich jemals in eine Abendveranstaltung eingeleitet sein, wo der Bundeskanzler kommt, ist mir die Tagesordnung da komplett egal. Herr Schulz, wir haben sich hier für einen Vortrag gebucht. Nein, während der Bundeskanzler redet, stehe ich auf und frage, sind sie bescheuert? Also nur für den Fall, dass er mich einlädt, das ist dann das Programm. Und ich möchte, dass jeder für sich eine ganz kleine Strategie, die man dann nicht erst, wo die Gelegenheit da ist und so, sondern das einfach mal durchvisualisieren, wie würde man in verschiedenen Situationen reagieren. So, und das dann einfach wie so ein Sportler, der schon mal in seinem Geiste den Hang runterfährt, das einfach üben, um dann im richtigen Moment zu handeln. Ja. Weil das, also das ist nicht mehr, ich habe jetzt schon gesagt, Kommunalpolitik ist mein neues Thema. Ich werde wahrscheinlich dann, was weiß ich, in zwei Jahren oder so ein Buch drüber schreiben. Darin wird es auch ein Kapitel geben. Das hatte ich mir natürlich schon länger zurechtgelegt, aber es wird immer driftiger. Kommunalpolitik heißt, man tritt vor die Tür, man sieht Sachen, man berührt Sachen, man hört Sachen. Also die eigene Sinneswahrnehmung ist erschöpft von dem, was man da wahrnimmt. Und wenn man eine Sorge hat, dann geht man zum Bürgermeister und sagt, ich hab hier ein Problem und sei es nur, dass man klingelt, wie auch immer. Da kann man also hingehen. Ab der Landespolitik, erst recht bei Bundespolitik und insbesondere bei dem allen, was wir aus Amerika sehen, das ist reine Fantasy, dass sich Leute noch damit beschäftigen, weil sie im Fernsehen glauben, als ordentlicher Staatsbürger gucke ich natürlich Nachrichten, nehmen das alles ganz ernst und da mach ich mir kurz Gedanken darüber, wie ich das jetzt finde, was in Venezuela passiert ist. Der Modus muss jetzt grundlegend geändert werden. Also alles, was wir bisher so in 80 Jahren Nachkriegsordnung, nachdem der Kaiser verschwand und wir so neue Orientierung geübt haben, scheint irgendwie in die falsche Richtung geführt zu sein.
Jaja.
Ich will es ganz deutlich sagen.
Man wundert sich ja manchmal, ich habe jetzt viele Romane gelesen aus dem 19. Jahrhundert, wie dort die Aristokratie mit ihren Angestellten umgeht oder sie noch nicht einmal in einem Roman beim Namen nennt. Also es gibt einfach nur irgendetwas, was aus der Küche kommt, wer das da macht, keine Ahnung. Es gibt irgendwelche Diener, die kein Gesicht, keine Namen haben und man fragt sich, was ist das eigentlich für ein Verhältnis zu anderen Menschen? Ja, also natürlich gibt es eine arbeitsteilige Gesellschaft und so kann es auch einen Chauffeur oder so geben, aber man fragt sich, was ist das eigentlich, dass also noch nicht mal mehr die einen Namen bekommen und man denkt sich, ja das ist diese überwundene Zeit, lange ist's her und dann liest man hier mit diesen Epstein-Files, dass wir es da nur mit Menschen zu tun haben, die sich als Elite begreifen und das auch ganz klar untereinander so kommuniziert und alles darunter muss dienen oder wird also eben wird nicht mehr mit den menschlichen Maßstäben behandelt. Missbrauch, alles ist dann möglich, denn die gehören ja nicht zur Elite, das sind irgendwelche Mädchen von irgendwo her.
Austauschbar.
Und Jungs, ja wohl auch, wie man jetzt immer mehr liest.
Zweckbezogen, genau. So eine deutsche Story finde ich wahnsinnig interessant, sie erfüllt mich auch ein bisschen mit Genugtuung, aber ich wirklich sehr wütend war. Über Jahre, immer wenn ich hier irgendwas mit Technik und KI und irgendwas weiter, also ich meine schon die Jahre auch vor Corona und so, gab es immer so eine Horde von Leuten, die mir in die Kommentare geschrieben haben, Stefan hat wieder keine Ahnung, er sollte mal mit Joscha Bach reden. Kann er nicht mal Joscha Bach in den Podcast einladen?
Ach ja, interessant.
Dann irgendwelche Links zu diesen CCC Vorträgen und so weiter. Und meine Antwort war immer, und ich sah es ihnen allen, die es gab, ich weiß nicht alle, aber sagen wir so ab 2013, also wenn Joscha Bach da auftrat dann beim CCC und so, weil ich jedes Mal da rein bin und mir dachte, mal sehen, was dieses Jahr wieder für ein Scheiß ist. Dann habe ich so einen kleinen Tweet dazu gemacht oder was auch immer. So und dass wir heute wissen, dass Joscha Bach intellektuell der allergrößte Hochstapler ist, der sobald er Texte vorgelegt hat, überall eine Abfuhr bekommen hat, in keiner Uni angestellt wurde, sondern immer nur, ja, der hat so Drittmittel selber mitgebracht und die sind alle von Jeffrey Epstein. Über eine Million Euro hat der Spiegel geschrieben. So, also dass da einfach eine Publikumsbespielung stattfand.
Und Flüge wurden organisiert, die Familie und und und, das war...
Um Leuten irgendwie einzureden, da sei was dran, dass die transhumanistische Zukunft der Mensch gelöst von seinem Bewusstsein und der ganze Scheiß. Das erfüllt mich so mit Genugtuung, dass ich euch allen jetzt sagen kann, die mir jemals so ein, Stefan hat keine Ahnung, soll man hier den Joscha Bach-Vortrag, ja? Ja, schaut ihr mal den Joscha Bach-Vortrag jetzt noch mal an und überlegt mal, warum hat er da beim MIT keinen Fuß in die Tür gekriegt, in Harvard nicht, in Stanford nicht und nirgendwo. Ja, warum ging das immer nur mit, ich habe meine Drittmittel dabei, ich brauche auch kein Büro, ich brauche hier nur einen Briefkasten und so, ja? Das ist einfach diese verlogene, intellektuelle Hochstaplerei, bei der wir jetzt wissen, das hat alles Methode. Das müsste man natürlich in riesigen, machen wir dann Ende des Monats auch, wie das alles mit Pizza Gate, warum 4chan, 8chan plötzlich so durchgedreht ist und so. Das ist ja alles so wahnsinnig.
Also wir müssen das noch größer aufgreifen. Ich hab jetzt mal nur einen Clip mitgebracht, denn wir kennen das ja noch alles von Corona, als uns natürlich zu Recht erklärt wurde, dass diese Verschwörungstheorien von wegen Bill Gates will uns chippen, idiotisch sind. Aber was im Zuge dessen auch passiert ist und das hat mich schon damals geärgert ist, dass plötzlich auch gerade aus einem linken Umfeld oder linksliberalen Umfeld Bill Gates plötzlich als der größte Wohltäter der Welt gesehen wurde und es wurde überhaupt nicht mehr über problematische Dinge bei ihm gesprochen. Nun gab es damals ja schon immer wieder diese Beziehungen, Epstein, Gates, was ist da dran? Wir wussten auch, ah ja, Melinda Gates hat sich scheiden lassen. Alles ein bisschen unklar, warum ist das so? Im Übrigen ja auch, wie dann hier auch von so Leuten, die die US-Demokraten ganz häufig in Deutschland immer wieder gesagt haben, ne, das hat nichts zu bedeuten, wenn Clisane Maxwell auf der Hochzeit der Tochter von den Clintons ist. Also ich weiß nicht, also ich frage mich jetzt, wenn jetzt über mich bekannt würde, ja, deutscher Filmkritiker hat jedes Jahr irgendwie Urlaub mit Harvey Weinstein gemacht, dann würde man auch mal vielleicht die andere Frage gerne stellen. Also dann sagt man ja nicht, ah ja, wird wohl, hat nichts damit zu tun.
Da sind ja tausend Leute eingeladen, weißt du.
Ja, da sind so viele Dinge, denen man doch eigentlich nachgehen müsste, schon seit Jahren. Und jetzt hat man diese Art der Veröffentlichung, du hast ja zu Recht darauf hingewiesen, es ist ein ebenso großer Skandal, dass die Beide Administration reingeschaut hat, wieder zugemacht haben und gesagt, ah, das lassen wir jetzt mal liegen.
Ja, das ist so krass. All diese Sachen tauchen ja nicht jetzt plötzlich auch. Das finde ich auch in der deutschen Diskussion immer. Das ist ja so eine typische journalistische Sprache. Der Epstein-Skandal zieht immer weitere Kreise. Als wäre das so ein Unwetter, dass jetzt gerade jemanden erwischt, weil ein Name wieder auftaucht.
Der ist seit über sechs Jahren tot.
Der ist seit über sechs Jahren tot. Die Leute haben seit 30 Jahren mit ihm zu tun. Also nur die Veröffentlichung zieht weitere Kreise, aber doch nicht der Epstein-Fall. Also es ist doch absurd.
Ja, und wir reden ja jetzt hier auch bei Melinda Gates von Vorfällen, die zwölf, dreizehn Jahre zurückliegen. Sie wird hier jedenfalls in dem Podcast Wildcard von Rachel Martin dazu befragt.
Ich muss den Elefanten in der Zimmererhöhung anerkennen. Dein Ex-Husband Bill ist in der neuesten Tranch von Epstein-Filen genannt. Und es gibt neue, beinahe Details über sein letztes Behaviour. Und ich möchte dir die Möglichkeit geben, in irgendeinem Fall zu reagieren, wie du willst.
Na, lass mich das sagen. Ich denke, wir haben eine Rechnung als Gesellschaft, richtig? Keine Frau, keine Frau sollte in der Situation, in der sie von Epstein und was auch immer mit all den verschiedenen Leuten um ihn herum geht. Keine Frau. Ich meine, es ist einfach, es ist über die Herzschmerzen, richtig? Ich erinnere mich an die Ärzte, die Mädchen waren. Ich erinnere mich an meine Tochter als die Ärzte, richtig? Also, für mich ist es persönlich hart, wenn diese Details aufkommen, richtig? Weil es die Erinnerungen von einigen sehr, sehr schmerzigen Zeiten.
Sie hat sich aber doch hier durchblicken lässt, dass sie offenbar Infos lange hat, die jetzt an die Öffentlichkeit gelangen und sie quasi auch Teil des Schweigekartells ist, auch wenn sie sich dann von diesem Mann aus diesen Gründen, die wir jetzt gerade erfahren, getrennt haben.
Also wir haben heute Bücher im Salon, die uns nochmal die 200 gängigen Denkfehler vor Augen führen. Also wir können unsere eigene Psychologie nicht überwinden. Und ja, sie gehört zu dieser Elite, die ganz nah dran war. Aber wir wissen auch, gerade in Ehen wird so krass viel versteckt, dass vielleicht gerade die Nähe auch wieder Distanz bedeutet, wie auch immer. Und ich finde, man sollte nochmal ganz scharf unterscheiden zwischen die, die jetzt auf jeden Fall Aussagen machen müssen. Also Bill Clinton, wenn der jetzt da vorgeladen wird vom Kongress und diese Gelegenheit nicht nutzt, einfach alles von sich aus zu erzählen, ein Jahr bevor er eh stirbt, sage ich mal grob, sondern jetzt Fragen kommen an ihn und er, wir sehen einfach, dass er ausweicht. Das wird ein ganz schlechtes Signal für sehr viele Leute sein, die dann, das muss auch eine Gesellschaft dann erst mal verarbeiten, dass da Leute einfach so mauern. Allerdings schon bei den Ehefrauen, die sich so äußern wie sie, würde ich sagen, es ist halt wirklich schwierig, dadurch, dass da psychologische Hürden sind. Sie zählt nicht zu den Täterinnen.
Nein, nein, das nicht.
Und ab da, ja.
Es ist nur interessant, dass sich jetzt aufgrund der Enthüllungen dann solche Äußerungen finden lassen von Linda Gates und von anderen.
Aber überleg mal, wie viel jetzt möglich gemacht werden musste, damit man sie zumindest bis dahin bringt, als so eine super mächtige, unabhängige Frau.
Und es geht ja jetzt noch einen Schritt weiter. Die Moderatorin fragt noch mal nach. Also sie ist froh, von all dem Dreck entfernt zu sein....
für Kontext für unsere Zuschauer. Die E-Mails und die File zeigen, dass Bill Gates zusätzliche Verhandlungen hatte und dass er versucht hat, Medikamente zu behandeln, um eine sexuell verabschiedete Infektion zu behandeln. Und dass er dir die Medikamente geben würde, ohne dich zu wissen. Sein Representative hat gesagt, dass all das falsch ist. Es ist nicht an dir, zu verantworten, was die Details des beobachteten Behördens sind. Aber ich frage mich, was deine dominanten Emotionen sind, wenn du diese Newsartikel mit diesen Details lernst.
Schmerz, einfach unglaubliche Schmerzen. Unverglaubliche Schmerzen, richtig? Und wieder, ich kann meine eigene Schmerzen nehmen Und siehst an, wie die jungen Mädchen sind und sagen, oh Gott, wie hat das mit diesen Mädchen passiert? Und für mich ist es einfach Schmerz. Schmerz für, ich hab meine Begegnung verlassen, ich hatte meine Begegnung verlassen, ich wollte meine Begegnung verlassen, ich hatte die Begegnung verlassen, ich musste die Foundation eventually verlassen. Also es ist einfach schmerzhaft. Das ist die Wahrheit. Und es ist irgendwie so wie, ah, zumindest für mich, ich bin in meinem Leben noch gar nicht so weit. Und ich hoffe, dass es jetzt ein bisschen justice für diese Frauen gibt. Wir sehen sie, die vor Mikrofonen in DC stehen. Was sie durchgeführt haben, ist einfach unvorstellbar, denke ich.
Ja, also, ja.
Man muss sich das mal vorstellen. Also Bill Gates hat dort Sex. Wir wissen nicht, ob er Sex mit Minderjährigen hat oder so. Wir lassen das hier natürlich alles offen und das werden die Recherchen dann ergeben. Aber er fängt sich da was ein und schreibt dann, als der Mann, der ja für Medikamente berühmt ist, dass er sie überall in die Welt bringt, schreibt dann Jeffrey Epstein. Hast du da mal ein Antibiotikum? Also stellt so Jeffrey Epstein die Frage, die man erst Chagypti stellt und dann dem Hausarzt. Also man geht, man sagt, da ist mir jetzt gerade ein bisschen unangenehm, ich frag lieber mal da nach. Und jetzt, also es ist ja auch so diese, und das ist, glaub ich, auch die Faszination, dieser, all dieser Fälle ist, dass es ja so, so unglaublich unwürdig ist.
Für den reichsten Mann der Welt damals?
Wie sich dort alle, alle verhalten, ja.
Es ist wirklich unglaublich. Jetzt gibt es natürlich die Forderung nach direkten Konsequenzen. Die sind sicherlich für Juristen, politisch Interessierte und so wahnsinnig interessant. Das wird auch noch sehr heikel und umständlich. Aber soziologisch interessant sind ja die indirekten Konsequenzen. Was bedeutet das jetzt grundsätzlich für alle Familien der westlichen Welt, in denen zum Beispiel die 17-jährige Tochter sagt, ich habe eine mega Gelegenheit bekommen, in der Vorstandsverwaltung in Manhattan bei so einer Firma mitzuarbeiten. So, da machen sich Familien plötzlich Gedanken. Ja. Und das wird auch zu Konsequenzen führen, halt indirekt so. Aber hier ist wirklich einiges in Bewegung. Also es ist wirklich, es ist auch crazy, dass das alles gleichzeitig passiert. Also hier unglaubliche Menschenverachtung, die da drinsteckt. Ja. Gleichzeitig diese Leute in Amt, ohne Würden, die dann Minneapolis und so, nochmal mit so einer Menschenunwürdigkeit überziehen.
Ja, in Davos erzählen, wir brauchen eigentlich keine menschlichen Beziehungen, sondern nur noch Roboter.
Genau. Also die politischen Mächtigen drehen komplett frei. Die ökonomisch Mächtigen drehen auch komplett frei. Es ist eine ganz große, dunkle Zeit der Orientierungslosigkeit. Und für Leute, die jetzt immer so Morgenmagazin gucken und dann hat Dunja Hayali, Luis Fanala, oder wie er heißt, zu Gast und fragt nochmal, was bedeutet das jetzt für die Midterms und so, ja. Also wirklich Schuss nicht gehört. Da kann ich auch diese Sätze mit, droht jetzt ein Bürgerkrieg, also der ist doch längst da, der ist in den Köpfen schon voll da. Ja, so. Die Frage ist jetzt, wie er ausgelebt wird und was auch immer, welche Möglichkeiten sich da geben.
Also mein Modus ist jetzt, sobald ich da jemanden von denen so sehe, also von diesen Eliten, dann sage ich, war der auch in den Epstein-Fights, google ich nochmal schnell nach.
Erst mal nach googeln, genau, wie viele Treffer.
Ja.
Und dann aber, es heißt ja nicht gleich, dass man da und so weiter, aber komisches Schutt.
Irgendwie so.
Und wir sollten uns ja auch bewusst sein, Epstein ist seit 2019 tot. Aber dadurch ist ja nicht das, was dort getan wird, einfach vorbei. Sondern wo sind die neuen Ringe? Wo passiert genau so etwas wieder? Das ist ja eigentlich die Frage. Und dann will ich nicht hören, wenn da wieder irgendwelche Verdachtsmomente kommen, dass man dann sagt, nee, nee, das ist Verschwörungstheorien. Und ich erkläre ihnen nochmal, wie Verschwörungstheorien funktionieren. Also ich wäre eigentlich mal ganz interessiert daran, wenn die, die uns in den letzten Jahren immer Verschwörungstheorien erklärt haben und uns gezeigt haben, wie falsch die alle sind. Wenn die mal gescheite Beiträge zu genau diesem Thema hier machen, das würde mich nämlich mal interessieren, wie die dem begegnen. Weil da kann man jetzt nicht einfach nur so Schulterzucken dastehen und sagen, ja, ach so, ja gut, da hat es dann mal vereinzelt was gegeben. Sondern das ist nicht vereinzelt, das ist flächendeckend und das ist alles viel größer, als die Skandale, die wir so in den letzten Jahren hatten, aus der Popmusik oder so. Hier haben wir eine Verwandlung von Kapital und politischer Macht und eben diesem missbräuchlichen Verhalten in verschiedener Hinsicht, dass man da eigentlich mal doch interessiert wäre, wie dort die großen Aufklärer zum Thema Verschwörungstheorie zu stehen.
Absolut. Bevor wir jetzt die Superreichen, ähm, wie heißt es nochmal, wenn man den alles wegnimmt? Besteuern?
Enteignen? Du bist jetzt beim Enteignen schon.
Radikale Enteignung. Ja, ja. Will ich noch mal einen Punkt machen, der jetzt gerade für uns aktuell ist, da Sebastian Seufert uns einen öffentlichen Kommentar schrieb, am 1. Februar zu einem anderen weltbewegenden Thema, nämlich KI. Wortlaut. Gut, dass du, er meint dich, Stefan re KI immer wieder einhegst, Wolfgang. Aber wie mir scheint, er wird einfach ein Krittin. Also jetzt, ich hab eine Aussprache Datenbank noch mal nachgeschaut, Krittin. Er wird immer ein Krittin bleiben, der in diesem Aspekt nur funktional denkt, auch wenn er ihr oft in die Oper geht. Was ist das jetzt so in Zusammenhang mit der Oper? Sehr viele Fragestellungen. Ich geh mal ein paar Fragen durch, die sich mir stellen. Der Krittin ist also jemand, der an Krittinismus oder sowas leidet. Das heißt, wenn man relativ früh so eine Schilddrüsen-Unterfunktion oder irgendwas hat und gewisse Entwicklungsstadien nicht überschreitet, also für immer so ein bisschen debil und blöd bleibt. Das ist jetzt eine Stellung für mich. So, die Frage ist jetzt, wenn ich über KI rede und ich will auf eine Pointe von letzter Woche, die schon jetzt drei Tage später quasi eine Megapointe oben drauflegen. Weil ich hatte ja kurz gesagt, Anthropic hat jetzt so ein Plugin veröffentlicht für Excel. Das heißt, alle Funktionen von Excel stehen jetzt plötzlich auf Zuhuf zur Verfügung. Man braucht keine Excel-Weitmeisterschaft mehr. Jeder kann das jetzt. Die Software, auf der das Ganze ökonomisch läuft, ist jetzt wie jeden. Nur eine Woche später möchte ich gerne fragen, ja, ich habe jetzt das Plugin, aber wozu brauche ich Excel? Wozu braucht irgendwer noch Excel? Ich habe meine eigenen Finanzdaten der letzten Jahre. Die Banken stellen sie ja mittlerweile als CSV strukturiert zur Verfügung. Ich gebe das einfach kloot. Ich sage kloot nicht mehr, bitte leihert es einmal durch Excel, je nachdem, welche Funktionen Microsoft sich irgendwann mal ausgedacht hat, die jetzt zur Analyse dienlich sind, sondern ich sage kloot, was ich will, unabhängig davon, welche Entscheidungen die fünf Billionen Firma Microsoft mal getroffen hat, was man jetzt mit solchen Daten macht. Also wir sind so jenseits von allem einfach, dass ich mir denke, diese Arbeitswelt, die wir gerade haben, die unter dem Diktum läuft, alles, was automatisiert werden kann, muss von Maschinen erledigt werden, weil ansonsten die Maschine mit dem Mensch im Wettbewerb steht und der Mensch diesen Wettbewerb immer verliert, muss hier ganz große Befreiung stattfinden. Was ja bedeutet, Leute, die jeden Tag acht Stunden starr auf den Computer schauen und allenfalls die Hand so ein bisschen bewegen, also sowohl Handgelenke als auch Nackenschmerzen bekommen davon und dann sozusagen Feierabend erleben, die müssen jetzt wirklich befreit werden. Und damit meine ich so ungefähr halb Deutschland. Also wir als Wohlstandsnation, in der jeder jetzt durchgesetzt hat, dass man natürlich einen Arbeitsplatz mit Tageslicht und so weiter hat, das sind ja genau diese Computerarbeitsplätze, diese Evolution der letzten 30 Jahre. So und jetzt ein Hinweis auf die Oper. Wir können nicht diese Arbeitswelt, wie wir sie haben, verteidigen, gegen Maschinen auch noch. Also nicht nur gegen Eliten, jetzt müssen wir auch noch gegen Maschinen verteidigen. Und dann einfach sagen, aber abends sind wir richtig Menschen und gehen in die Oper. Also das ist einfach, das passt überhaupt gar nicht zusammen. So wenn ihr glaubt, das ist ein geschlossenes, auch noch sozusagen plädoyerfähiges Weltbild, dann möchte ich nicht, dass da die Oper drin vorkommt, weil ich sehe da ganz andere Sachen. Ja, das ist einfach völlig absurd. Also bitte jetzt im Kopf auch ein bisschen upgraden. Es ist immer schön, sich über mich lustig zu machen, weil ich alles mit KI mache und so. Gerne, also her damit. Aber nicht in dieser Art und Weise, dass man den einen Menschen als biologisch beschädigt nach der Geburt darstellt, der einfach Entwicklungshirten nicht nimmt. Aber zum Glück noch in die Oper geht, du Opfer. Also da wirst du noch mal angesungen und kannst passiv vertragen, was andere sich toll ausgedacht haben. Es ist ja völlig so gestört, kann man gar nicht sein in seiner linken intellektuellen Blasenhaftigkeit.
Meinst du, das war ein Linker?
Ja, da ich mittlerweile ja sage, wir müssen überhaupt über alles nachdenken, ja verwende ich links natürlich auch nur noch als Beschimpfung hier. Also wirklich schlimm. Wolfgang macht mit euch die Verteidigung der Bullshit-Jobs auch nicht so.
Nee, das will ich ganz klar sagen. Ich verteidige nicht die Bullshit-Jobs. Ich bin etwas skeptischer, was das anbelangt, was durch die KI ersetzt werden kann. Ich glaube, dass das doch zum Teil kompliziertere Aufgaben sind im Sinne von, es braucht zwischenmenschliche Interaktion, um diese Dinge zu lösen. Aber klar, diese Fälle, die wir haben, wo man sagt, da muss jemand Excel-Tabellen einfacher ausfüllen. Und da fehlt nur noch jemand, dass wir das Programm haben, dass uns das einfach automatisiert macht. Da bin ich überhaupt kein Verteidiger. Zumal wir ja beide große Profiteure genau all diese Entwicklungen sind. Also dass man mit Diepel sich alle möglichen Seiten übersetzen lässt, dass man diesen Podcast, du schneidest ihn ja, aber dank KI und so auch in einer anderen Geschwindigkeit schneiden kann, als das sonst üblich wäre. Dass wir eben diese ganzen Möglichkeiten haben, der Recherche durch KI. Also ich bin jetzt niemand, der irgendwie sagt, schade, dass wir jetzt in dieser Welt angekommen sind. Und das wäre aber toll, wenn wir Jobs verteidigen, bei denen viele Leute ein sehr entfremdetes Leben führen. Also das kann ja nicht der Sinn sein. Weil dann sind wir wirklich in der Konstellation, die David Graeber beschreibt. Also da ging es ja dann darum, wie könnte man eigentlich das Versicherungssystem und all das vereinfachen und das wäre möglich. Und Obama wird darauf angesprochen und sagt, ja, das würde so viele Jobs kosten. Also man lässt es einfach unnötig kompliziert, um dann zu sagen, oder ich habe ja selbst damals, man kann es wirklich nachhören, vor dem Salon, war das glaube ich, oder direkt im Salon zu der Graeber-Folge, habe ich damals gesagt, ich habe einen Bullshit-Job ausgeführt. So, und was war mein Bullshit-Job an der Uni als wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter? Nicht nur, ich will jetzt nicht nur klagen, aber ein doch nicht ohne erheblicher Bestandteil war der, dass ich von meiner Doktor-Mutter Aufsätze bekam, die sie geschrieben hatte und die angepasst werden musste, dem jeweiligen Style-Sheet, den die unterschiedlichen Verlage haben. Das heißt, die einen machen da ein Semikool, und die anderen da einen Komma, und da einen Doppelpunkt, und da ein Anführungszeichen, und dort Fett gedruckt und sonst was. Und das ist einfach eine Arbeit, die in keiner Weise sinnvoll ist. Das ist eine Arbeit, die nur Fleiß bedeutet, und man muss sich höllisch konzentrieren, weil man natürlich lauter Fehler macht, dass man dann sagt, komm mal Punkt, ist mir doch jetzt egal. So, und wenn man das nun einfach Vibe, mit dem Vibe, ich hab keinen Bock, liebe KI, mach das mal hier, das ist ja dieser Style-Sheet, dann kann man damit einfach diese Bullshit-Shops wegfallen lassen, beziehungsweise die Zeit, die Bullshit-Zeit kann man dann wegfallen lassen. Und ich hätte in der Zeit mich zum Beispiel lieber mit den Studenten unterhalten und denen in irgendeiner Weise weiter geholfen, statt so einen Unsinn zu machen. Und davon gibt es schon sehr, sehr viele Tätigkeiten. Und wenn diese Tätigkeiten von der KI übernommen werden, dann ist das sehr gut. Nämlich dann ist das eine wirkliche Entbürokratisierung, die stattfindet.
Genau. Wenn ihr wollt, dass eure Eltern später von Menschen gepflegt werden, müsst ihr euch halt dieser Technologie zuwenden, die die Menschen, die eure Eltern pflegen, davon befreien, irgendwelche Berichte zu schreiben und so. Das ist einfach völlig eins plus eins ist hier zwei. Und dass es dann noch Elon Musk daneben gibt und seine Anhänger, die dann sagen, ey, die Betreuung des Hundes, er wird jetzt der KI übergeben, das ist halt deren Problem. Aber das ist ja nicht, ich bin ja nicht deren Verfechter. Das wird jetzt die Altenpflege, die Kindererziehung und die Haustiere an die KI-Auslage.
Ja, ich glaube, dass du manchmal gerne so die anthropologische Philosophie überspringst und dann die KI in einer Weise als Denken des Wesen uns darstellst, dass wir oft, zumindest wenn du mit uns sprichst, mit mir und den Hörern, den Unterschied zwischen dem Menschen und der KI nivelliert bekommen. Und da ist der Punkt, wo ich dann hier einhaken und sage, so geht es ja nicht.
Ich kann jetzt aber nicht noch ein drittes Buch über Familie schreiben.
Familie und KI vielleicht.
Ja, da wo KI nichts zu suchen hat. Familie.
Das wäre ein guter Titel, da wo KI nichts zu suchen hat.
Aber das kann man sich auch selber denken. Manche Sachen sind einfach zu offensichtlich, als dass ich da jetzt noch mal Hünschmalz einlege, den Leuten zu sagen, ne bitte, Elon Musks Idee nicht ernst nehmen. Also da muss einfach ein kloster Podcastzuruf reichen. Und das ist dann auch so.
Ich mach den Zuruf dann.
Gut, genau. So, jetzt nehmen wir den Reichen alles weg, was sie haben. Ihr Geld, ihre Würde, ihr Intellektuelles und so weiter, Selbstverständnis. Diese Clip-Rundowns hier laufen auf einen Jahrhundert-Clip hinaus. Ich möchte es nur schon mal anteasern. Wir hören jetzt ein bisschen Lars Klingbeil und ein bisschen Robert Alexander. Und danach kommt ein Jahrhundert-Clip. Also Lars Klingbeil zum Vorstoß.
Der Finanzminister drängt auf eine Reform der Erbschaftssteuer. Die Erben großer Vermögen sollen konsequent und in erheblichem Umfang zur Kasse gebeten werden. Ungerechtigkeiten dürfen wir nicht hinnehmen, mahnt der Vizekanzler.
Ich habe bei mir mal auf dem Dorf gelernt, du strengst dich an und du kommst in deinem Leben voran. Aber du kannst heute der Beste in der Schule sein, die Beste in der Ausbildung, im Studium, der Fleißigste im Job und du wirst dir keine Eigentumswohnung in Berlin, in Hamburg oder in München leisten können. Wenn du gut geerbt hast, dann ist das der Fall. Und das verstößt gegen das Leistungsprinzip.
In der CSU wollen sie davon nichts wissen.
Ja, die CSU, die CSU, die CSU. So, Lars Klingwald ist Finanzminister. Er könnte ja auch ein innerliches Argument mit Cancell-Fund machen, weibt aber so vor sich hin, was ich nicht gut finde. Denn das Programm der SPD ist ja viel besser. Zum Glück gibt es ja noch die Tagesthemen. Also ganz kurz hören wir hier diesen einen Punkt, der ganz wichtig ist in der Diskussion.
Auch bei der Erbschaftssteuer für jedermann schlägt die SPD eine Reform vor. Aktuell dürfen Elternteile alle 10 Jahre 400.000 Euro an Kinder vererben oder verschenken, steuerfrei. Stattdessen soll jeder Mensch künftig einen sogenannten Lebens-Frei-Betrag in Höhe von einer Million Euro erben können, ohne dies besteuern zu müssen. Das selbstgenutzte Eigenheim soll außerdem steuerfrei bleiben.
So, alle 10 Jahre 400.000 Euro, niemand versteht das. Das ist so völlig Nonsens. Es ist einfach, da könnte die Philippa Segel-Klöckler wieder ein gutes Geldbuch drüber schreiben und sich fragen, wo kommt diese Zahl her? Ja, keine Ahnung. So, ja, das ist völlig absurd. Aber was jeder versteht, eine Million Euro und das Haus der Eltern. Das prägt ja die Diskussion heute, dass irgendwelche Leute glauben, sie müssten das Milliardäre verteidigen, weil sie ja mal ein Haus erben. Und dass die SPD ja einfach sagt, wenn du nur das Haus deiner Eltern erbst, bist du nicht superreich, dann bist du einfach gar nicht gemeint. Und das ist ja einfach diese Million pro Person, wo einfach jeder von sich selber kurz, da muss man nicht mal, also mit Leuten schon mal gar nicht reden, da muss man nicht mal die KI fragen. Ich kann mich einfach kurz drüber nachdenken. Eine Million? Bin ich Millionär? Nee, okay, gut, dann bin ich raus. Wenn du nicht Millionär bist, bist du hier raus. Das bedeutet, von den 85 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland sind schon mal 83 Millionen hier gar nicht gemeint. Für die wird eine Steuerbefreiung, nicht mal mehr eine Steuersenkung, sondern eine Steuerbefreiung stattfinden. Die SPD möchte dich von Steuern befreien.
Ich möchte den Vorschlag ergänzen, denn ich finde das immer noch komisch, dass wir so viel in den letzten Jahren darüber geredet haben und auch rechtlich einiges umgesetzt haben, um die Kernfamilien nicht als das einzige mögliche Modell zu denken. Und man aber beim Erben immer noch so dabei ist, dass man steuerfrei vererben kann, bis zu einem gewissen Betrag, wenn es die Eltern an die Kinder sind. Aber dass es zum Beispiel Freunde nicht können. Nun stehen aber viele Leute, den Wahlverwandten viel näher als der eigenen Familie. Ich verstehe nicht, warum hier immer noch diese Unterscheidung aufrechterhalten wird. Das geht ja bis in die Linkspartei, zumindest in Teile der Linkspartei hinein, dass man immer noch diese Unterscheidung macht und man einfach sagen müsste, ja, dann soll die Person diese Millionen erben können. Und dann geht es auch nicht darum, wer ist jetzt wie gerade verwandt. Das ist alles unsinnig in meinen Augen.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, also ob das so stimmt, denn das Erbe und das Schenken ist so ziemlich gleichlautend im Gesetzestext.
Ja, aber bislang ist es ja immer noch so geregelt, dass wir eine höhere Erbschaftssteuer haben. Also wenn du mir jetzt was vererbst, dann muss da eine viel höhere Erbschaftssteuer drauf gezahlt werden, als wenn meine Eltern mir was vererben. Das ist ja so.
Das kann sein.
Und da gibt es ja noch mal einen anderen Verwandtschaftsgrad. Wenn du jetzt mein Onkel wärst, dann hätten wir so einen etwas besseren Steuersatz. Aber wo wir gar nicht miteinander verwandt sind, würde dann eine entsprechend hohe Steuer abfällig werden. Ich sage nur, man machte eine Unterscheidung plötzlich da zwischen Familie und Nichtfamilie, wo wir zugleich einen gesellschaftlichen Diskurs haben, wo man sagt, ja meine Freunde sind auch meine Familie.
Das ist ein anderer Punkt. Ich müsste selber noch mal nachgucken, weil jetzt triggert mich das natürlich. Denn die 400.000 Euro Freibetrag pro Kind alle 10 Jahre ist ja keine Erbe, sondern das ist ja eine Schenkung.
Das ist ja auch eine Schenkung.
Weil das ist ja noch nicht elternteilig gestorben. Und bei dem sehr berühmten Fall, Matthias Döpfner kriegt eine Milliarde, das war ja auch jenseits der Geburtenfolge, also er war ja nicht die Tochter von, sondern es war ja auch eine Schenkung. Und er hat dann trotzdem im Rahmen dieser Schenkung die Bedarfs- Verschonungsbedarfsprüfung. Also ist ja wirklich alles zur Erbschaft.
Ja, ja, aber das Erbrecht ist in Deutschland immer noch an der Familie ausgerichtet. Das ist auf jeden Fall wichtig. Wie das jetzt mit den Schenkungen geregelt wird, wird man sehen. Aber man kann auch in den Vorschlägen, zum Beispiel zur Erbschaftssteuer bei der Linkspartei oder so, stark sehen, dass man eigentlich an dem Modell festhält, dass sozusagen das Haus der Eltern und so etwas eine andere Rolle spielt, als wenn du mir jetzt ein Haus vererbst. Und das halte ich für falsch.
Und da kann man immer wieder auch auf diese Pointe nur hinweisen, dass wir das bei der politischen Macht absolut ausgeschlossen haben. Also da muss so ein Kreichen sofort zurücktreten, weil da waren mal Trauzeuge irgendwo. Also die Vererbung von politischer Macht, sofort Fett am Wirtschaft, das machen wir nicht, das ist Korruption, wie auch immer. Vererbung ökonomischer Macht, das Selbstverständlichste auf der Welt. Da fand Null Modernisierung die letzten 300 Jahre statt. Das ist schon interessant. So jetzt Robin Alexander in seinem Machtwechsel-Podcast. Vielleicht hören wir hier schon, wie das so ist, wenn man Podcasts ohne Springer im Hintergrund macht. Wir können das ja mal überprüfen.
Ja, also ich finde das Argument, das Urteil kommt erst in ein paar Monaten und...
So, also hier die Diskussion kennen wir ja, dass die CSU und die CDU jetzt immer kommen und sagen, warum kommt denn die SPD jetzt mit Vorschlägen zur Erbschaftssteuerreform? Es dauert doch noch eine Weile, bis das Bundesverfassungsgericht dazu in Urteil spricht, wo ich mir denke, es ist doch super klug, in dem Moment dann was in der Schublade zu haben, dass auch allen schon so ein bisschen bekannt ist, wie zum Beispiel eine Million Euro, du bist frei. Und sei es für die Diskussion, möchte ich nicht einforderstellen Sachen, aber es geht nicht um dich, sei dir das bewusst. So, und dass überhaupt jemand in der CDU kommt und sagt, das ist ja ganz doof, dass die sich schon mal das Feld bereiten für die Diskussion und so. Ja, du denkst, der macht doch einen Gehvorschlag.
Vorher dürfen die Parteien dazu nicht sagen. Das verstehe ich nicht, weil, glaubt man zu wissen, in welche Richtung das Urteil geht. Und zweitens, Parteien tragen zur Meinungsbildung bei. Also ich möchte das SPD-Konzept kennen und ich möchte auch das CDU-Konzept kennen und sonst.
So hört das sich also an, wenn Robin Alexander nicht mehr bei Springer ist und nicht mehr der CDU das Wort redet und uns erklärt, was Merz wieder Kluges gemacht hat und warum es jetzt ganz wichtig ist, ins Detail zu gehen. Ja klar, das macht doch voll Sinn, dass eine SPD zur Willensbildung beiträgt. Wer kann denn da was dagegen haben?...
um mir eine Meinung bilden zu können. Also die Strategie der CDU, bis das Urteil kommt, sagen wir hier gar nichts, die erschließt sich mir nicht. Also da finde ich, da bin ich eher bei der SPD. Und die SPD hat natürlich einen Punkt, selbst wenn man geschworener Marktwirtschaftler ist, wie wir beide, dazu müssen die Hörer wissen, bei Dagmar Rosenfeld zu Hause steht eine kleine Statue von Ludwig Erhard.
Genau, ich habe dir sozialen Marktwirtschaftunterschlupf gewährt.
Aber selbst wenn man halt so drauf ist wie wir, muss man doch sagen, das große...
Immerhin wird das jetzt reflektiert. Ja....
Argument gegen die Erbschaftssteuer ist ja, bereits versteuertes Einkommen wird dann nochmal besteuert. Und man nimmt den Leuten einen Leistungsanreiz, weil ein sehr gesunder Leistungsanreiz ist, ich möchte gerne meinen Kindern was vererben, dass meine Kinder es mal besser haben. So, das ist das Argument dagegen. Nur das Argument dafür ist natürlich in einer Vermögenssituation, die immer weiter auseinandergeht in der Bevölkerung, kommst du irgendwann zu so einer krassen Verzerrung der Ausgangslage, dass du keine Leistungsanreize mehr hast, dass die geschwächt werden. Das ist das Argument, das Lars Klingbeil zum Beispiel bringt. Er sagt, man kann arbeiten, wie man will. Man kann sich keine Eigentumswohnung in Berlin mehr leisten und das ist nicht in Ordnung. Und ich finde, das ist ein Argument, wenn man mit Christdemokraten abseits der Mikrofone spricht, sind die dem durchaus zugänglich.
Ja, was man ja mal festhalten kann ist, also Amlinger und Nachtweih machen dieses Buch zerstörungslos und reden dort von blockierten Leben, was dazu führt, dass Leute sehr wütend sind und lieber alles zerstören wollen als und so weiter. Was wir auf jeden Fall haben, selbst bei den Leuten, die nicht ein blockiertes Leben in sich spüren, ist, dass wir eine blockierte Republik haben. Leute können nicht mehr umziehen, weil sie sich das nicht zutrauen, weil ich kriege ja keine Wohnung und dann hänge ich, was mache ich dann ein Jahr lang in Stuttgart, so bis ich da und so weiter. Also wir sind hier sehr, sehr, sehr blockiert einfach. Und deswegen nutzt Robin Alexander nicht nur die Gelegenheit, dass die CDU noch nicht sprechfähig ist, aber legt den schon mal Argumentationen in die Worte, um ihn dann zu widersprechen, sondern obwohl die SPD selber ja gerade sehr redselig ist, bringt er sogar deren Punkte noch mal selber in seine Diskussion ein.
Also die Lage ist ja jetzt, dass durch die Gesetzgebung etwas entstanden ist, dass die Erbschaftssteuer eigentlich eine dummen Steuer ist.
Ja, das traut sich die SPD nicht zu sagen. Aber es ist ja genau so. Also traut sich jetzt Robin Alexander das einfach zu sagen, weil es ist ja so. Ich finde, hier weht schon neuer Wind durch diesen Machtwechsel-Podcast. Das ist ganz erstaunlich.
Über die Freibeträge so arbeiten, dass man fast nichts zahlen muss. Und irrerweise, je mehr man erbt, desto weniger muss man zahlen. Da gibt es den Begriff der Verschonungsbedarfprüfung und die fällt an, wenn du mehr als 26...
So, Verschonungsbedarfprüfung. Warum durfte man da unter Springerdach nie drüber reden? Ach ja, wegen Topfnau und der Milliarde und so.
Ja, ja, das ist genau das, was ich hier Punkt.
Das ist natürlich jetzt hier ein bisschen anders.
Wenn du Millionen Euro erbst, also in diesem Wert, dann musst du in der Regel keine Erbschaftssteuer zahlen. Und hier sieht die SPD auch einen Kampagnenmoment und ich glaube, die CDUs, die CSU sind gut beraten, das ernst zu nehmen, weil das Argument, wenn du ein Haus erbst und dieses Haus steht in einer guten Lage, dann musst du über das, was über den Freibetrag hinaus ist, Steuern zahlen für das eine Haus, was du erbst. Wenn du 301 Häuser erbst und die vorher in eine Immobilienfirma getan worden sind, dann musst du keine Erbschaftssteuer zahlen und das verstößt gegen das Gerechtigkeitsempfinden von weiten Teilen des Volkes. Ja, genau so ist es.
Wir wollen gar nicht in das Sprechen gehen.
Deswegen hören wir hier mal weiter. Das ist ja unglaublich.
Ja, ein spektakulär faszinierendes Manöver muss man auch erst mal drauf kommen. Du stellst ein Konzept vor und an der entscheidenden Stelle trägst den X ein, nämlich wie hoch sind die Steuersätze? Sie sagen nur Progression nach dem Freibetrag. So, und wenn das so bliebe, wie es jetzt ist, dann wäre es ja in der Spitze 50 Prozent, dann wäre es zu hoch. Dann müssten viele Leute die Unternehmen verkaufen. Also das kann es nicht sein. Aber das Interessante ist, dass die SPD jetzt nicht gesagt hat, wir stellen ein in sich geschlossenes, vernünftiges Konzept vor, sondern eben extra diese Lehrstelle programmiert hat, gegen die jetzt die Union polemisieren kann und dann aber gleichzeitig der Union die Möglichkeit eröffnet, in Verhandlungen zu treten und zu sagen, guck mal, jetzt haben wir aber schöne, niedrige, vernünftige Sätze reinverhandelt. Also sie haben quasi der Vernunft und dem Koalitionspartner das gleiche Türchen offen gelassen, was schon echt ein spannendes Manöver ist.
Ja, hört, hört, Leute.
Hört, hört.
Letzter Clip dazu. Wir wollen natürlich jetzt, wo gerade die große Ehrlichkeit hier einzieht, in der deutschen Podcastlandschaft noch mal hören. Wer ist jetzt unser aller zentraler politischer Feind?
Seit 20 Jahren doktert die Politik an diesem Problem rum und das Verfassungsgericht sagt immer wieder, so geht das nicht. Und die beiden Kernargumente des Verfassungsgerichts sind, ihr müsst die Leute gleich besteuern und ihr dürft nicht ohne wenigstens zu prüfen Steuern erlassen. Und Per Steinbrück, Roland Koch, Wolfgang Schäuble, also ja nicht die Schlechtesten, haben sich daran versucht. Und warum sind die gescheitert?
Ich sage nur drei Buchstaben CSU.
So ist es. Die CSU hat sich immer auf den Standpunkt gestellt, das geht alles zu weit und wir sind die Schutzmacht der Familienunternehmen und auch der anderen Unternehmen.
Sag mal, haben die beiden das Buch von Martina Linatas gelesen?
Also es ist ganz erstaunlich. Alle jammern immer rum, weil das Jahr so und der Januar allein alles so dramatisch. Aber der Machtwechsel-Podcast ist dramatisch besser geworden.
Wir wollen schauen, ob das so bleibt, aber hier ist es wirklich ganz bemerkenswert.
So, jetzt kommt dein Jahrhundert-Clip, es ist wirklich ganz erstaunlich. Wir sprachen schon mal über den All-In-Podcast. Drei Milliardäre und jemand, der nur 600 Mio. Dollar auf sich vereint. Was bedeutet? In Amerika gibt es gerade 350 Mio. Menschen, aber nur 2000 Milliardäre. In Prozenten, wir reden ja mal gerne von den 99%, den 1% usw. Dieser Podcast wird gestaltet, von den 4 Leute, von denen 0,0001%. Wir sind ja noch jenseits von allem, was wir je in Büchern gelesen haben. Wenn man in Büchern mal so, bei Milano wird es so, 0, also die 1%, die 01%, werden vielleicht nochmal die 001%er. Aber jetzt hören wir die 0,0001%-Klasse. Die Billionär-Klasse. Und David Friedberg, ich stelle ihn nur kurz vor, war einer von den ersten 1000 Mitarbeitern bei Google. Direkt mit Larry Page gearbeitet. Wahrscheinlich sehr umtriebig. Insgesamt ist er durch die Lande gefahren, hat gesehen, das Wetter ist voll und voll bedeuert. Also die Climate Company gegründet, die also Wetterdaten verkauft. So ein bisschen wie hier Kachelmann das ja auch macht. Also das große Angebot, wie wird das Wetter bei uns, wird es glatt und dann aber so ganz punktuell auf deinem Acker, auf deinem Firmengelände, wann muss hier abgepumpt werden, wie auch immer. Und diese Firma hat Monsanto damals gekauft für 1,1 Billi, also Milliarden, weshalb er seitdem Milliardär ist und dieser Umtriebigkeit halt weitergeht. Und er macht jetzt folgende Beobachtung. Und wir hören jetzt nicht nur, was zu erwarten ist, und zwar einer ganz schönen A, B Dichotomie, sondern auch, warum sind die eigentlich so reich? Wir können jetzt mal hören, was er erklärt, warum die so reich sind und uns fragen, hat das mit irgendeinem Leistungsgedanken noch zu tun? Das meine ich jetzt nicht auf dieser vulgärartigen, da arbeiten andere für dich oder so, sondern es sind doch, wie man jetzt so hört, ganz große politische Wetterlagen, die irgendwas mit Zinsen und der Fett und irgendwas mit der globalen Wirtschaftslage zu tun haben. Und gar nicht so sehr mit, ob überhaupt noch jemand arbeitet oder so. Also hier bei David Friedberg aus dem All In Podcast Episode 259 im Januar, da hört man es mal ganz deutlich.
Ich möchte nur noch einen letzten Punkt machen. Es ist ein Moment der De-Dollarisation. Es ist immer wert, eine Reflexion darauf zu haben. Aber ich möchte es einfach zurück zu Minnesota, Donald Trump und Sozialismus. Und ich denke, es ist wichtig für uns, dass wir es nur bezeichnen, dass wenn ihr Inhalte habt, wie wir, die vier von uns, wir haben Inhalte, wir haben Real Estate, wir haben andere Inhalte. Und wir werden wealthier und wealthier und wealthier. Die Mehrheit der Amerikaner hat keine Inhalte. Sie sind nette Inhalte negativ. Als Ergebnis leben sie aus Inhalt. Und sie benötigen sich nicht von der Inhalte, sondern von der Inhalte, die sich in der Inhalte befinden. Und das ist das, was die Populismus in den USA effizient. Und die Populismus in den USA ist das, was den Sozialismus betrifft. Und die Response zu diesen Behavioren ist das, was Donald Trump gewählt hat. Und die Response zu den Donald-Trump-Aktionen ist das, was die zivilen Unreste in Minnesota und anderen Orten betrifft. Ich glaube grundsätzlich, dass viel der Unreste, der zivilen Unreste, und letztendlich dieses Verbrechen in diesem Land, durch den Fakt, dass die Dollarisierung wegen der überwachtigen Regierungsschweite letztendlich die Mehrheit der Menschen in diesem Land zu fühlen, verletzt und hinterlassen, weil sie sehen, dass ein paar Menschen in diesem Land ihre Netzwerten zerstören, wie wir alle hier sind. Und es gibt keinen Weg für sie, sich zu fassen, denn sie haben keine Inhalte. Ich werde mit euch ehrlich sein und eine Konfession machen. Ich war heute Morgen im Gym auf der Treppe. Du warst im Gym? Ja. Und während ich da war, dachte ich über das Wachstumsteuern, das in Kalifornien passiert ist. Und ich frage mich, ob es eine Unwahrheit ist, um die USA von einer Zivilwahl zu halten. Ich meine das sehr ganzheitlich. Und die Frage ist, ob man es violence oder non-violente machen kann.
Ja, sehr erstaunlich.
Er war heute Morgen im Fitnessstudio, hat sich mal kurz so Gedanken gemacht. Und meine, krass. Wir sind ja vor einem Bürgerkrieg. Außer wir kriegen noch mal eine zivilisierte Umverteilung hin.
Ja, dass er dafür bis ins Jahr 2026 schreiten muss, um bei dieser Kenntnis anzukommen, ist dann ja immer ganz bemerkenswert, aber so ist es dann.
Hier hört man jedenfalls nicht raus, dass die Milliardäre sind und dann noch mehr Milliarden haben Jahre später, weil irgendwer fleißig gearbeitet hat, weder sie selbst noch ihre Mitarbeiter, sondern hier gibt es einfach Großwetterlagen in Währungsdissbalancen. Und ja, dann wird das halt ausgeglichen durch politische Versuche, dass durch hier noch Dollar drucken und da und 30 Billionen Schulden kommen, legen wir noch drauf und so weiter. Und wir wissen ja, wie dieses Geld dann fließt. Jeder, der im Supermarkt feststellt, es ist aber teuer hier, ja, das Geld ist dann nicht weg. Es hat nur die Seite gewechselt. Ja, und es ist halt irgendwo und da ist es halt.
Ja, in Bilanzen denken wir jetzt gleich auch im Salon. Noch ein kleiner Hinweis, am 13.2. bin ich mit Ole in Hamburg.
Welche Städte?
Erzählen wir, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das heißt jetzt gerade, jedenfalls erzählen wir dort die deutsche bundesrepublikanische Wirtschaftsgeschichte anhand von Schlagern.
Ist sehr gut. Stellt ihr euch da auch eine Statue von Ludwig Erhard hinten ins Bücherregal?
Nein, aber Ludwig Erhard wird bestimmt auch fallen, dieser Name, aber vielleicht dann doch.
Singt ihr diese ganzen Schlager?
Wir singen nicht alle Schlager, aber wir werden auch singen. Wir werden auch singen, aber wir werden nicht alle Schlager singen. Das wäre ein bisschen viel.
Okay.
Jetzt aber zu unserem Salon. Wir wollen unseren Blick weiten ins Globale. Das tun wir mit Patrik Kacmarczyk. Der hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Zerfall der Weltordnung, die Ignoranz des Westens und der Aufstand des globalen Südens. Bei WestSent erschienen. Es ist ein Buch, das uns mitnimmt in die großen Institutionen, die wir eigentlich fast nie kritisch beleuchten. Was tut eigentlich der IWF? Was ist mit der Weltbank? Inwieweit oktouieren wir den armen Ländern Austeritätspolitik auf? Wie sind sie abhängig davon, wenn jetzt gerade der Dollar mal so oder so von der FED ausgerichtet wird, wenn wir eine Hochzinspolitik haben? Was bedeutet das eigentlich in den anderen Ländern? Es ist ein Buch, das uns mit Wahrheiten konfrontiert, wo man eigentlich sagen muss, mich wundert ja, dass überhaupt noch jemand aus dem globalen Süden mit uns spricht. Jetzt kann man sagen, die Alternativen sind auch nicht so grandios, aber es ist wirklich so drastisch, wenn man das alles mal so aufgeschrieben bekommt, in sehr knappen Kapiteln uns erklärt wird, wie das wo funktioniert. Argentinien wird hier als Beispiel uns auch sehr genau erläutert. Es ist tatsächlich ein Buch, das einen auch mit Wut erfüllt, weil man so, also diese Ordnung, die als Ordnung immer beschrieben wird, war halt immer eine Ordnung für uns. Und für andere bedeutet das eigentlich Willkür und Chaos.
Ja, das sagst du so. Also ich habe mir beim Lesen auch die Frage gestellt, wer ist hier eigentlich globaler Süden? Ich habe da Sachen wie Ostdeutschland gelesen, bei denen ich mir denke, schön und gut, dass Amerika der Weltpolizist ist, aber wenn er in Minnesota auftritt, dann kann man nicht einfach sagen, oh zum Glück bin ich Amerikaner, ich bin hier geschützt. Sondern da richtet sich die Ordnung doch gegen viel.
Ja, also diese...
Die regelbasierte Ordnung.
Ja, also diese ganze marktliberale Ideologie wird hier sehr gut analysiert und wirklich auch anhand der Institutionen gezeigt, wie es funktioniert. Das ist also das Buch, über das wir gemeinsam diskutieren. Außerdem gibt es von mir wieder ein Musik-Tipp, Klavier-Trio. Dann fragen wir uns, gibt es einen neuen faschistischen Körper? Und wenn ja, wie sieht er aus? Dagmar Herzog hat dazu ein Buch geschrieben, dann lange schon angekündigt, jetzt endlich Thomas Wagner, Wege aus der Gewalt, Impulse für neues politisches Denken. Gibt es also eine Möglichkeit, jenseits des Sozialstaats zu denken? Außerdem blicken wir auf die Streaming-Plattform MUBI, die sich enorm entwickelt hat, aber jetzt doch auch mit einigen Ärgernissen zu kämpfen hat. Und wir schauen uns noch an, wie eigentlich Öl von Venezuela nach China gelangt. Da gibt es eine Recherche aus dem Handelsblatt.
Brauchen wir keine Pipeline? Nein. Okay, sehr gut. Das nicht über Politik reden Buch schieben wir nochmal auf für ein anderes spektakuläres Buch. Ich war so gefesselt, selten war ich so gefesselt von einem Buch. Ich habe es gehört, von der Autorin selbst gelesen, Julia Anders Organisch. Es kam schon im August, ich habe es gar nicht mitbekommen. Aber sie hat nach damit Charme zehn Jahre als Ärztin hinter sich gebracht und hat jetzt ein neues Buch vorgelegt. Das ist wirklich ein Spektakel. Und sagen wir mal so, unter den Gesichtspunkten, hinter den Wir, der Körper im Faschismus, der Körper als Sinngebung fürs Leben, die KI hat keinen Körper, was bedeutet das alles ja? Wird mir richtig gut aufgeklärt. Dann stelle ich zwei Texte gegenüber, die New York Times. In search of a platonic co-parent. Leute nutzen es nicht nur um eine Datingplattform, sondern sie suchen auch Leute, mit denen sie Kinder großziehen können. Und sie sagen ausdrücklich, ich will schon weiter rumdaten und so weiter, mir geht es hier nur um die Kindererziehung. Und das gleichen wir danach ab mit diesem neuen Text von der Heritage Foundation. Saving America by Saving the Family. 150 Seiten Policy Paper. Ich weiß nicht, also die drehen mittlerweile so am Rat, das ist wirklich unglaublich. Und zum Abfluss Dario Amodei, der Anthropik-Chef. Von dem haben wir ja schon diesen Text geschrieben, Machine of Loving Grace oder sowas, wo so die utopischen, wir werden alles 40 mal schneller entwickelt und so weiter und so fort. Er hat jetzt einen zweiten Text geschrieben, den hat er ja auch da wo es schon so ein bisschen angekündigt. The Adolescence of Technology. Dieser Text ist sehr lang, was ich witzig finde, da wir alle wissen, also schon ohne KI schreiben diese Leute diese Texte nicht selber, mit KI und vor allem mit eigener, wissen wir ungefähr, wer diesen Text geschrieben hat. Also habe ich ihn auch von Claude lesen lassen. Wir lesen also nur, was Claude mir gesagt hat, was in dem Text drin steht.
Und darauf vertraust du, dass Claude das kann?
Also wenn mich Claude jetzt belügt, dann wurden wir halt hin ins Licht geführt und der Amodei hat über was anderes geschrieben und ich frage mich, ja und? Es ist ja nur ein literarischer Beitrag, was?
Was heißt nur ein literarischer Beitrag?
Naja, der Typ weiß, also der hat für sich entschieden, dass er seine Ideen über Technologie in die Welt bringt. Ja. Ich frage mich, warum schreibt er überhaupt Texte? Ehrlich gesagt ist das auch bei Palantir und The Technological Republic so. Dieses Buch, da wir es sehr kritisch lesen können, schadet ja eher dieser Mission, weil es doch sehr viel Skepsis unterfüttert, die man Palantir entgegenbringen kann. Also wir hätten sehr viel weniger Argumente, dem Bayerischen oder baden-württembergischen Grünen nochmal zu sagen, warum sie Palantir, wenn er das einfach nicht geschrieben hätte.
Ja, genau.
Genauso wie zu Guttenberg jetzt Bundeskanzler wäre, hätte er einfach keine Dessertation geschrieben. Also Texte können auch schädlich sein für die Leute. Und in deren Sicht finde ich es schon witzig, dass er auch nochmal im Sinne von für ihn nur Literatur vorlegt.
Gut bei Guttenberg ist es, glaube ich, etwas anders. Da geht es um Zertifikate zu erhalten. Aber hier in diesen Fällen möchte ich jetzt ganz klar sagen, diese Leute sind ja so von sich überzeugt, dass sie eigentlich so eine Verfassung schreiben. Ja, so muss man das eigentlich sehen. Sie so, wie würde ich jetzt eine Verfassung schreiben? Ich stelle mir mal folgendermaßen die Welt vor, ich schreib es mal genau nieder. Und so machen das die ja eigentlich, dass sie sagen, also auch Antriessen Horowitz, die auch immer solche langen Texte herausgeben, die schreiben gerne so auf, wie sie die Gesellschaft haben. Also man könnte dann sagen, aber wir haben doch hier schon Grundgesetz rumliegen. Ja, nee, interessiert mich nicht. Ich habe mir jetzt eine eigene Verfassung.
Okay, dann frame ich es anders. Superreiche, supermächtige, super schöne Leute lassen sich morgens eine Morgenlage vorlegen. Wir kennen sehr viele Leute, die daran arbeiten, Mick zum Beispiel, die so eine Morgenlage aufbreiten. Also es gibt Leute, die lesen wirklich, was in der Welt steht und andere kriegen dann so ein Deserat, sag ich schon, so ein Konzentrat.
Und du machst das jetzt im Prinzip mit der KI auch, wie die Mächtigen sagst, leg mir mal eine Morgenlage vor.
Also ich bin sehr gespannt, falls es Diskussionen dazu gibt. Also die Kritik nehme ich gerne entgegen, dass ich ja den Text von Dario Amodai nicht vollständig über meine Augen konsumiert habe, während wir alle wissen, wer der Autor ist und welche Technologie er in Anschlag bringt und so weiter. Also für die auch witzig.
Das alles werden wir gleich diskutieren, besprechen, empfehlen im Salon. Den Salon kann man hören, wenn man ein Abo abschließt. Es ist also ein Zusatzinhalt zu Die Neuen Zwanziger. Manchmal muss man es noch mal dazu sagen, weil manche glauben auch, es ist ein einfach getrennte Podcast oder so. Nein, es ist ein Zusatzinhalt zu Die Neuen Zwanziger und das ist auch der einzige Weg, Die Neuen Zwanziger, die ja frei verfügbar sind, zu unterstützen. Wir freuen uns, wenn ihr das tut. Das ist möglich über Apple, da kann man das mit einem Klick abonnieren, kommt dann auch zu den alten Folgen. Man kann, wenn man schon bei Patreon angemeldet ist, dort auch ein Abo abschließen bei Die Neuen Zwanzigern. Wir empfehlen allerdings Steady. Dort hat man die beste Übersicht auf wirklich das Gesamtachief und mit drei Euro im Monat ist man dabei und hat dann aber auch immer Zugang zu allen alten Folgen und zusätzlich natürlich auch zu den Live-Salons, die wir in Frankfurt veranstalten. Auch die werden ja aufgezeichnet.
Genau.
Und man kann sich, wenn ich das noch anfinde, auch schon eine andere Besprechung anhören. Wir haben nämlich von Patrick Hartz-Marsch schon mal ein Buch gelesen, nämlich Kampf der Nationen. Da geht es um den tollen Wettbewerb innerhalb Europas und wir gehen jetzt quasi so auf den globalen Rahmen und schauen uns, wie der Wettbewerb stattfindet.
Das ist dann der Februar 2022-Salon. Claude hat mir nämlich eine schöne Übersicht gebaut. Ich kann sofort alle meine Notizen reinkommen. So, was ich sagen wollte, weil du sagst, das ist der Zusatzinhalt, das stimmt. Aber wenn ihr bei Steady euch einen Account macht, dann das Geld bezahlt und dort Zugriff auf den Salon habt, dann ist der Salon sozusagen ein eigenständiger Podcast. Also wenn ihr dann in die Apple Podcast App geht, weil das eure Lieblings-Podcast-App ist und ihr nehmt den RSS-Feed des Salons, den ihr von Steady bekommt und ihr tragt den in der Apple Podcast App ein, dann ist in der Apple Podcast App der Salon ein eigener Podcast. Ihr seht dann trotzdem immer noch die von Apple angebotenen Salon-Folgen im allgemeinen Podcast. Aber das darf euch bitte nicht länger verwirren. Ich habe jetzt ein paar E-Mails dazu geschrieben. Apple weiß nicht, dass ihr Salon-Abonnenten seid. Euch wird also das dort nicht einfach ausgeblendet, sondern das ist halt trotzdem da. Aber ihr habt ja schon den Salon als eigenständigen Podcast. Ihr könnt also diesen teureren Button-Click da einfach ignorieren, denn es ist ja derselbe Salon.
Genau. Und man kann dann über diesen RSS-Fit, den man von Steady erhält, generell alles hören. Das heißt, man muss nicht noch zusätzlich Die Neuen Zwanziger noch mal irgendwo anders abonniert haben, sondern es reicht eigentlich. Mit Steady ist man rundum versorgt.
Genau. Wenn ihr bei Steady-Abonnenten seid, könnt ihr überall anders den Podcast ignorieren, denn ihr bekommt ja auch die Monatsfolge ohne Werbung im Salon-Fit dann bei Steady.
Und jetzt noch zum Schluss, wer das gerne lieber verschenken möchte, kann das auch tun. Für ein Jahr kann man via Steady den Salon verschenken. Außerdem freuen wir uns, wenn ihr überhaupt den Salon und Die Neuen Zwanziger weiterempfehlt und den Podcast positiv bewertet. Ich würde sagen, genug der Werbung. Wir gehen jetzt hinein in den Salon.
So ist es.